[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 25
avril deux grands compositeurs pour des
musiciens en devenir les élèves de
l'orchestré symphonique de versailles
grand parc répète depuis le début de la
semaine pour un grand concert cet homme
entre dans une danse intense et
acrobatique la compagnie masala présente
la semaine prochaine elle encourt sa
nouvelle création nasse où se mêlent
danses traditionnelles et hip hop un
atelier nomade des rénovations des
visites à rambouillet les prochains mois
vous entraîne à la découverte de
l'histoire et notamment celle du palais
du roi de rome
il répète inlassablement six heures par
jour depuis le début de la semaine les
élèves de second cycle des
conservatoires de versailles grand parc
forme actuellement un orchestre
symphonique le fouet de leur travail
sera à écouter vendredi 27 avril marion
tac pour les images
[Musique]
l'arlésienne dans un écran celui du
théâtre montansier c'est la cinquième
édition du stage de l' orchestre avec
cette année à sa tête constante en huit
chefs d'orchestre de l'opéra de massy
qui a choisi de leur faire jouer de la
musique de scène
musique de scène on a pris ça de manière
extrêmement large la musique de scène
c'est la musique pour qu'ils
accompagnent le théâtre donc on a la
musique de l'arlésienne de bizet qui
accompagne le théâtre la musique de
scène c'est aussi la danse évidemment
avec la le tchaïkovski et la valse des
fleurs
la musique de scène c'est aussi le
cinéma aujourd'hui en afrique l'un des
yakin le derby
depuis lundi ils répètent assidûment aux
instruments des musiciens en
apprentissage les élèves de second cycle
des conservatoires de l'agglomération de
versailles grand parc mi mars on
affichait déjà un déchiffrage tous
ensemble maintenant c'est vrai que le
travail
l'instant de la semaine par par pupitre
par instrument ça va être un problème
important pour pour les pour les détails
là aujourd'hui
ben du coup ces revues pour réputé
morceau je les connais ces semences à
des points et ça dépend des morceaux aux
lyonnais qui sont plusieurs comiques
bizet tchaïkovski ou encore beethoven
résonneront ce vendredi les musiciens
n'attendent plus que vous pour valser
[Musique]
les pompiers sont au secours de
l'environnement les personnages de la
bande dessinée sont les héros du
prochain agenda scolaire de versailles
grand parc
quatre classes ont planché sur les
illustrations de cette nouvelle édition
est le thème de cette année les déchets
michael almy d'euros s'est glissée dans
la classe je travaille sur les bulles et
l'écriture est alors au passage aux
autres est un personnage dans la maison
en flammes et des nuages
j'ai dessiné des des fenêtres des
tableaux et personnages leurs pompiers
prennent vie pour porter secours à
l'environnement cette classe de cm2 de
versailles participe à la sixième
édition de l'agenda scolaire un projet
pluridisciplinaire autour des déchets on
a travaillé en sciences on a travaillé
en production d'écrits on a travaillé en
recherche
mais la finalité c'est d'arriver à ses
planchers au travail voilà ça c'est la
finalité du projet pour aller aux jets
aux éco-gestes faut d'abord connaître et
comprendre les enjeux qu'il ya derrière
quand vous prenez une bouteille de jus
d'orange le matin il pourrait fléchir de
façon systémique dont il eut bien
comment on les crée comment il a été
produit et qu'elles vont être ses
déchets près 220 enfants quatre classes
de l'agglomération de versailles grand
pas qu'ont travaillé deux jours avec un
bédéiste cette année c'est stedo
dessinateur belge alors
ils ont plein d'idées plus que moi du
coup c'est un peu frustrant mais non
mais je suis assez surpris parce que
c'est quand même un projet concerne
conséquent au niveau du boulot à
investir et je trouve qu'il voit là ils
ont plein d'idées ils sont très réactifs
il dessine vachement bien en fait donc
voilà je pense que je vais les engager
les élèves ont donné avant les vacances
leur dernier coup de crayon plus de dix
mille exemplaires de cet agenda seront
distribués dès le mois de juin
édifié sur ordre de louis seize devaient
palais du roi de rome à rambouillet et
reconstruit par ne peut pas napoléon 1er
pour son fils le roi de rome
et sur ces prochains mois de nombreux
rendez vous vous y attendez pas
seulement pour tout connaître de ses
découvertes avec nous en plateau el gahs
brillante et royer bonjour bonjour alors
vous êtes la responsable du patrimoine
de la vie et pour les beaux jours
notamment on peut rentrer dans les
secrets du palais voilà c'est ça
actuellement nous accueillons une une
exposition atelier qui partie destinée
aux enfants qui s'appelle chic une
grande maison emprunté à la cité de
l'architecturé du patrimoine et qui
invite le jeune public et leur famille à
reconstruire un hôtel particulier donc à
prendre conscience que le palais du roi
de rome était un hôtel particulier entre
cour et jardin à la française puisque
aujourd'hui c'est un bâtiment qui est
mutilé une partie du corps central a
disparu et là dans l'atelier c'est
surtout pour les enfants et se
transforme en petit architecte c'est ça
les enfants reçoivent une commande donc
un commanditaire farfelu leur passent
commande fait part de ses goûts de ses
désirs ce qu'il aime ce qu'il aime pas
il ya des contraintes de règlement
d'urbanisme qui sont donnés également et
les enfants à l'aide de très grands
modules en bois doivent construire un
hôtel particulier en tenant compte de la
commande et d'automne compte de la
commande de huit personnes si je me
trompe pas il faut bien réfléchir à
comment l'agencé on peut même penser au
jardin c'est ça le jardin est impératif
puisque le principal modèle particulier
d'être entre cour et jardin voilà c'est
un petit îlot qui se tient en lui même à
l'intérieur de la ville il ya une autre
exposition juste à côté un peu plus
historiques notamment donc vous retracer
l'histoire du palais du roi de rome qui
a une histoire très importante et aussi
un autre bâtiment on connaît un peu
moins oui vous avez rencontré il ya
quelques mois parce que le pavillon du
verger va connaître une nouvelle
métamorphose oui il va être restaurée
alors l'expo dossier plus exactement
elle retrace l'histoire du premier hôtel
du gouvernement donc le bâtiment qui
avait précédé le palais du roi de rome à
l'époque de louis saez et l'histoire
également de ce qu'on appelle maintenant
le pavillon du verger qui a été intégré
dans son jardin mais qui préexistait qui
était une commande des années 1770 du
duc de penthièvre qui était propriétaire
de rambouillet avant louis saez est donc
ce petit bâtiment 18e qui a conservé un
décor intérieur des années 70 ce qui est
de transition louis 15 oui c'est donc
c'est très rare parce que la transition
s'est faite très rapidement entre le
style oui 15 et le style louis saez donc
a pas beaucoup d'exemples était resté à
l'abandon durant longtemps puisqu'il est
passé en mains privées à la révolution
est là pas été entretenu il ya eu des
couches de peinture sur couche de
peinture qui ont été rajoutés sur le
décor intérieur est donc là il ya un
projet de restauration
donc le budget a été voté les appels
d'offres vont être lancés et les travaux
démarreront à l'automne pour 18 mois à
deux ans même dans les petits bâtiments
il ya des trésors
oui nous explique l'histoire de
rambouillet le palais du roi de rome
aujourd'hui il a toujours une histoire
particulière c'est un lieu d'exposition
mais j'imagine que vous ont profité pour
faire visiter
oui les lieux alors le palais du roi de
rome pas la partie publique en tout cas
puisqu'il ya une partie qui est privé
puisque le bâtiment s'est retrouvée
coupée en deux dans les années 1830 donc
accueille des expositions accueille des
collections permanentes et on a profité
de l'exposition chic une grande maison
pour essayer de le montrer un peu plus
au public tard qu'on présente souvent
l'aspect architecture monumentale et
moins les aménagements intérieurs qui
sont à complètement perceptible il faut
vraiment regarder donc on a appelé cette
visite les secrets du palais du roi de
rome
on invite le public à regarder
l'intérieur du mode nom de très près et
à retrouver ses traces qu'ils nous
disent comment étaient les aménagements
intérieurs ou des arrivées
voilà ce qu'on y vivaient dans
quel espace comment c'était à ménager
certains espaces ont été modifiées mais
d'autres sont encore très perceptible
et puis on peut comprendre aussi à part
les documents d'archivés pourquoi après
tout là il ya une porte il ya un espace
vide qui sert plus à rien mais c'est
parce qu'avant il y avait un dégagement
avec une garde-robe
au départ ça se comprend comme ça et
puis du coup on les fait un petit peu
passer par les coulisses aussi les
endroits où ils ne vont pas
habituellement
il sera à découvrir d'une autre manière
en corse que le 19 mai c'est la nuit des
musées donc les fumeuses et ferment plus
tard et là on était architecte on se
transforme détective c'est ça alors on
ouvre pour la troisième fois à
l'occasion de la nuit des musées
et cette année alors dans le programme
qui sort là qui démarre en mai il n'y
avait pas encore le titre mais je peux
vous le donner ça s'appellera le murmure
de la berceuse et donc c'est une
histoire de morts mystérieuses avec un
enfant disparu et les visiteurs devront
résoudre cette énigme
ce sera le moyen de le voir sous un
autre angle aussi un relais les plus
jeunes c'est en fin d'après midi mais
les a doublées eux auront accès le soir
c'est ça alors pour les plus jeunes je
crois que c'est 17h30 19h et à partir de
14 ans parce qu'il faut être plus grand
nombre de morts mystérieuses à partir de
21h jusqu'à minuit et après on va ça on
va aller un peu plus loin la chaleur art
il était arrivé il y a des rendez vous
aux jardins des malades des visons que
le service du patrimoine participent
aulas rambouillet ville d'art et
d'histoire donc depuis très longtemps
maintenant au rendez vous aux jardins
donc premier week-end de juin le 3 et le
4 je crois cette année de mémoire donc
nous proposons cette année une visite du
parc grousset qu'un parc contemporain
avec la particularité qu'il y à un
partenariat avec le poney club et que
les jeunes enfants qui a kong
accompagnent leurs parents durant la
visite sont invités à le faire à poney
c'est moins fatigant pour les petites
jambes
il ya des trésors aussi à découvrir dans
ces jardins des choses qu'on ne verrait
pas s'ils ont visité par nous-mêmes
peut-être des rageux je crois alors un
aspect historique sur le pack de
grousset pas vraiment puisque c'est un
jardin très récent par contre il est lié
à la question de la présence de l'eau à
rambouillet puisqu'avant l'état jonah
d'agrément c'est une un bassin de
stockage en fait qui permet à la ville
de ne pas être inondées trop souvent
puisque l'eau commence par ceux stockés
dans le parc qui a été conçu pour ça au
départ est ensuite si vraiment il n'y a
un trop plein et évacuées vers les
jardins du château en ouvrant des vannes
et on espère généralement ça suffit donc
on aura aussi des visites en dehors des
rendez vous aux jardins sur le thème de
l'eau à rambouillet qui est très présent
puisque la ville est dans une cuvette
donc historiquement ça a été important
dans la les aménagements urbains
la première vocation des canaux du pacs
et de drainer le sol en fait et ce sont
des visites qui s'adresse à qui les
enfants peuvent y aller alors les
enfants sont toujours les bienvenues
dans nos visites les visites du dimanche
après midi sont quand même plutôt des
visites tout public dont qui vise les
adultes mais les enfants sont toujours
les bienvenues qu'on a vraiment une
politique d'accueil envers les familles
et puis en parallèle il peut avoir aussi
des propositions beaucoup plus jeune
public
donc on a pris le parti de programmer
juste après les visites secret du palais
qui sont certains dimanches après midi
un atelier animé chic une grande maison
mais chic une grande maison lieu
d'ailleurs le 6 13 et 27 mai ces cinq
heures voilà donc chic une grande maison
et accessible librement on peut aller et
jouer en famille sans guide conférencier
mais on peut aussi participer à un
atelier animé par un guide conférencier
des ateliers avec le git vont peut-être
un peu plus loin dans l'exposition
peut-être répondre aux interrogations
oui c'est ça le guide en fait en profite
pour présenter le monument lui même on a
une maquette qui montrent le monument à
son état d'achèvement avant la coupure
des années 1830 et puis les plus grands
ont un petit bout de visible de
coulisses
merci el gahs brillante et rouillée
alors pour ne rien manquer des
rendez-vous rambolitains bien sûr
direction le site internet de la ville
il était dans invité la semaine dernière
les membres de l'association tous pour
réussir organisé leur premier festival
un festival tourné vers le rire retour
sur cette première édition
nicolas landry pour les images déjà on
va voir si son show pour la danse et de
lumière la vie de ma mère moi on dirait
un interrogatoire ils sont trappistes
yvelinoise franciliens leur mot de
ralliement ce samedi c'était le rire
rire de tout et de tout le monde rires
de la société de la famille des amis
faute aussi à l'humour ça donne de la
joie voiture surtout ils ont un
quotidien pas semble difficile nous que
nous arriver et que quand on sort d'un
bon spectacle
bon on est cordon sur la scène de la
salle jean baptiste clément des
comédiens mais aussi des chanteurs des
danseurs des hypnotiseurs on attrape et
de 2 c ça fait partie de ma ville je
vois là quoi c'est pour ça que j'ai
accepté ça et puis pour que
tout le monde mon courage pour voir ce
qu'il ya des arbres voilà il ya des
artistes qui peuvent sortir de deux
secteurs un peu plus reculé que paris
même et pour que les jeunes puissent
s'amuser valoriser en fait les pendants
des jeunes comme les jeunes souvent
oubliée au stigmatiser ces artistes
amateurs ou confirmés participe au
premier festival du rire un festival
pensé par tous pour réussir une
association trappistes nés en 2009
ces plateaux de ce festival la va
essayer de réunir un petit peu tous les
squares de trappes qui sont un petit peu
ta vue individuel tous à construire tous
ensemble pour essayer de partager un bon
moment avec les humoristes témoins ont
participé une dizaine d'artistes a
répondu présent pour cette première
édition l'association espère grande son
rendez vous annuel
et comme chaque semaine c'est le moment
de notre coup de coeur cinéma
[Musique]
cette semaine on part au grenier à sel
de trappes galles pineau un rendez vous
à vous donner
il y a un an et demi le cinéma le
grenier à sel s'est associé avec la
compagnie déclic théâtre qui est donc la
compagnie de trappes de théâtre
d'improvisation pour la création d'un
tout nouveau genre de spectacles cinéma
qui s'appelle plan c'est le cinéma
improvisé les il ya cinq comédiens sur
scène est un musicien le public décide
du thème musical et du thème visuel
c'est totalement improvisée donc les
comédiens ne savent pas ce qui va se
passer
et à partir de ces éléments visuels et
sonores ils vont devoir inventer un
nouveau film et pendant la soirée ils
vont inventer trois films ce sera donc
le jeudi 3 mai à 20h45 au cinéma le
grenier à sel
il faut réserver sur le site de déclic
théâtre mais de vous trouver tout ça sur
notre site internet cinéma grenier à sel
point com
m
à la ferme de bel ébat la compagnie de
d'un groupe présente whitman
et mme colle leur dernière création
s'inspire du célèbre film le cercle des
poètes disparus
il raconte l'histoire d'une jeunesse qui
souffle sur les flammes de la terreur
pour danser sur les cendres avec joie à
découvrir les 4 et 5 mai prochain au
théâtre alphonse daudet de coignières de
public est invité dans une rue celle où
deux immeubles sauf font face et où vit
carmen une petite fille de 11 ans qui
n'a pas le droit de sortir seules le
soir mais en hardy elle décide de se
lancer regarder derrière les fenêtres de
ma rue je vois des gens un peu mou tordu
des tristes démarche mais mal foutu dès
qu'ils ont peur dès qu'ils ont vu
dès qu'ils pleurent en regardant la
bouffe lui dès qu'il gueule comme des
arbres utiles au thème personne même pas
le chien dès qu'ils se couchent tôt le
masters à la batterie de guyancourt ce
sera du rock ce vendredi à 5 mai sur
seine reuters mind la nouvelle formation
de jim jones
extraits
[Musique]
et
nos essais les âges
[Musique]
mais les filles
ciao
[Musique]
des danses traditionnelles mêlé à du hip
hop avec une touche électro
il est difficile de résumer nas est la
dernière création de la compagnie masala
et son chorégraphe c'est fois debout
souffle on regarde un extrait ils sont
aux prises miles en cours le jeudi 3 mai
[Musique]
et fois que vous souffle est avec nous
en plateau bonjour bonjour alors vous
êtes le chorégraphe de cette compagnie
la compagnie masala lacets nas je le
disais de salaires des danses
traditionnelles avec du hip hop une
touche électro c'est un spectacle vous
mêlez vos influences
oui tout à fait ce sont les inspirations
d'afrique du nord et de france une pièce
tryba donc là aux inspirations
africaines plutôt du côté du sahara où
c'est une géographie plus large plus
large je m'inspire de là
des traditions d'avoir en fait qu'ils
sont un mélange de cultures nord
africaine et d'afrique subsaharienne
alors on a des danses guerrières on a
des danses festives comment vous les
avez choisie elle arrive à un moment ou
un autre de la chorégraphie elles sont
elles existent parce que les danseurs
les incarnent en fait et c'est le
travail d'une année un peu plus qu'une
année d'ailleurs avec les danseurs où on
a on a su voilà les les prendre à bras
le corps et puis les laisse entière pour
mu les diffuser ensuite alors là c'est
le titre ça ça signifie les gens mais
qui sont ces gens ce sont vos sept
danseurs ce sont les gens que vous
croisez ceux de votre histoire à vous je
crois que c'est un peu tout le monde
c'est une pièce universaliste c'est une
pièce qui traîne qui traite de de
l'humanité en général avec justement les
représentants qui sont ces sept
personnes qui sont des hommes mais qui
représente largement les hommes avec un
grand h
alors vous avez fait venir vos
influences africaines mais vous y mettez
du hip hop de ces la formation vous
venez ou c'est une danse aussi qui vous
inspire parce que c'est là c'est là dans
ce que j'ai découvert quand j'étais
adolescent c'est la danse qui m'a fait
grandir parce que c'est un espace de
liberté ça l'est toujours
j'espère et parce que c'est aussi une
danse que les danseurs connaissent
puisqu'ils sont d'obédience hip hop on
va dire et parce que la danse hip hop
est beaucoup plus vaste que qu'il n'y
paraît 06 pop mais ils ont tous des
formations assez diversifiée vous êtes
aussi inspiré de cela de toutes leurs de
toute leur formation de tous leurs
bagages ou c'est d'abord vous qui a
amené les éléments c'est un échange
permanent
en fait il ya une forme
d'interdépendance entre le danseur et
moi et ce qui m'intéresse d'ailleurs
c'est autant le parcours de danseur que
que leur parcours de d'êtres humains en
fait c'est ce qui m'intéresse vraiment
le plus est que des hommes certaine
force ces violences pour les dons vous
aussi c'est un challenge d'abord de
chorégraphier 7,7 jeune homme c'était
une première pour moi et aussi parce que
il ya bien un lien fort avec ses danses
tribales il ya quelque chose de deux oui
une forme de violence aussi que je
ressens une tension
psychologique même en afrique et en
afrique du nord c'est ce que j'ai voulu
mettre en scène
on l'a entendu quand on a diffusé des
extraits tout à l'heure il ya une
certaine touche électro on le trouve
dans la musique de romane bestion
pourquoi l électro dance hall avec des
mélanges de musique africaine parce que
je crois qu'on n'a rien inventé du tout
et la musique électro elle s'inspire
aussi de ses rythmes lointains et de ses
rythmes qui dépasse le à mon avis le
cadre typiquement musical je crois que
c'est des musiques qui nous voilà qui
nous font vibrer tout simplement
c'est une composition inédite il l'a
fait pour vous comment vous l'avez
rencontré ce compositeur alors roman
c'est une longue histoire parce qu'on
devait travailler ensemble en 2013 déjà
pour un premier projet qui s'appelait
trans en lien avec cette thématique de
danses d'afrique du nord avec les
connexions danse hip hop et on s'est
retrouvé avec le temps et l'huile a
composé cette création avec simplement
de danse traditionnelle danse unique
pardon traditionnel de nass el ghiwane
car un groupe moins chère à mon coeur
est et une musique de haas et d'arabes
le reste est composé spécifiquement pour
cette pièce vous disiez tout à l'heure
un an de travail
c'est c'est une pièce qui a été dur à
faire ressortir au contraire ça a été
très rapide
comme toute création c'est difficile
c'est le long celle lancée compliqué il
ya eu d
des changements de distribution de
danseurs puisque c'est une pièce
exigeante
ce conte et 55 minutes sur scène on ne
sort pas j'ai dis toujours on même si je
ne danse pas mais je fais partie du
musée avec je vienne avec eux et c'est
une pièce qui demandent donc à la fois
une très très bonne condition physique
et puis aussi une grande disponibilité
pour être à 100% pendant 55 minutes et
puis aussi être à nu
quelque part avec une danse hip hop
condense pieds nus c'est aussi ça aussi
le challenge ça change les peut-être les
appuis quelque chose qui n'est pas bien
sûr on a l'habitude on est au chaud sur
l' on l'a vu sur les images a beaucoup
d'appui différents ça saute
c'est vous l'avez leur avait demandé une
certaine condition c'est peut-être même
technique les deux les deux c'est une
pièce vraiment exigeante physiquement
techniquement et qui met à nu le danseur
sur scène sert qu'on on est à nu dans le
sens où on est visible tout le temps et
il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de refuge
en fait ce n'est pas de refus ne serait
ce que dans la sténographie oui vous
avez choisi un plateau nu des costumes
très très c'est pas le mot ne lui
mettrai simple commun comment on
pourrait les croiser dans la rue et qui
se met à danser c'est les gens c'est des
gens est une super scénographie signée
camille vallin avec un très beau tableau
en fond de scène un et de manière
minimaliste mais très très puissante qui
racontent beaucoup de choses votre
compagnie c'est la compagne des masses à
la ville a fondé en 2006 le métissage
c'est un mot d'ordre pour vous toujours
dans toutes vos oeuvres ou lui au
contraire vous je suis en quête
permanente influence jeu
j'observe ce curieux et le métissage
pour moi il est pile était une évidence
au départ pour moi le fait de rencontrer
des danseurs de deux issus de divers
parcours de diverses origines
pour moi c'était une évidence donc gg
voilà j'ai pas réfléchi plus que ça en
fait pour moi c'était évident dans
l'époque dans laquelle je m'inscris donc
vous ne restez pas sur une seule
influence sur une seule culture c'est
vraiment pas être en fonction des gens
que vous croisez je crois je crois que
les influences à sont là aussi elles
sont liées aux rencontres et jean combes
beaucoup de gens et je m'attache est
forcément
je me laisse aussi je me laisse
influencer quelques parce que je crois
qu'on a on a beaucoup à découvrir d
autres
merci une fois que boussouf alors votre
nouvelle création sénat salle est à
découvrir au prisme des longs cours
c'est le jeudi 3 mai c'est la fin de
cette étude culture et je vous remercie
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
mercredi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]